we've seen gbtc and the grayscale team
they're trying to convert into an etf uh
their most recent application was denied
uh and so within hours they went ahead
and they began the process to sue the
sec their argument is the sec has
already approved uh futures based etfs
both long and short there's other spot
bitcoin etfs around the world we don't
have one here in the united states i
don't know how much you can comment or
not but what's your general take on
bitcoin spot etf in the united states
and maybe grayscale's chances to be the
first to get that conversion
yeah um
here's how i look at it from the
perspective of working in financial
services and working within the system
on a regulated basis and i have for
years
suing the sec
is a really bad idea
it it virtually never works they have
unlimited resources it's a bravado thing
to do and i'm sure others in the
industry are applauding this
but the outcome is never good because
they don't like getting sued
and they have
tremendous powers to avoid being
embarrassed and trying to embarrass the
regulator into submission
well pomp that just doesn't work
and so
um this is not the path of least
resistance
and i i do not want to you know comment
on
on what they're attempting to do other
than saying from my point of view it's a
personal opinion
it borderlines it you know it borders on
insanity
it's it's not a good play book and i i
think if i were on that board
um
i would be i would be pretty noisy in in
in the boardroom about this now having
said all that i'm more optimistic on
other strategies in terms of getting
some policy in crypto
and i you know we we should talk about
the next six months because
you've got
lots of evidence now of bipartisan
interest in getting some policy in place
not in a combat way by suing regulators
but in a way in cooperation
on a bipartisan basis and let's make it
real easy okay we're not going to get
everything regulated overnight we may
not get an etf in the u.s for two or
three more years but that's not the only
thing that matters
what i'd like to see and a lot of others
too
would take one asset
one asset a really
bipartisan asset
in the form of stable coin now not all
stable coins were created equal we know
the meltdown and luna that story is well
known algorithmic based you know stable
coins may not be the best idea be very
hard to launch another one but assets
like usdc
that are backed by the us dollar have
not broken a buck recently
and
if that was made
and was allowed to be regulated it could
become the default payment service for
the world backed by the us dollar
because everybody would use it
because so many commodities including
oil are actually paid in u.s dollars
imagine if you could use usdc to
transfer between jurisdictions and
geographies it's far more efficient
better ledger more transparent lower
cost way faster
what senator
doesn't like that idea making the us
dollar king dollar
keeping it at the supreme default
currency i don't care what party you're
in that's a good idea
the policy being proposed by the toomey
and hagerty bills and even contemplated
in the limits bill which has much more
than just stable coin let's just take
the stable coin
if toomey's going to retire in january
he's he would endorse this if he could
get it passed
in the last by the last and the end of
this year it would be a fantastic thing
and everybody in the crypto industry
including all the institutions that
don't own it yet would see the very
first marker
of policy on a very basic asset
stable coins and
contemplated in the policies very simple
full audit every 30 days what's wrong
with that makes sense to me and no
assets held supporting the token or coin
with a duration longer than 12 months
what's wrong with that that looks like a
money market by fidelity or by schwab
i've been talking about this now for
three months and i'm really working hard
going to washington trying to do
whatever i can as a private citizen to
push that agenda just one thing let's
get one thing done and i will also note
since you and i last talked that
fidelity and blackrock each put in 200
million dollars that's a lot of money
into a series f
that circle
now that if that isn't accommodating and
supporting the notion of a regulated
stable coin i don't know what is what
what isn't i mean that that is as good
as it gets those are the most
conservative financial institutions in
the world supporting the idea of a
stable coin backed by the u.s dollar
talk to me about disclosures you
mentioned obviously luna there's a lot
of people who had questions there we've
seen many other companies uh that have
struggled over the last couple of months
and it feels like alongside this idea of
more regulation is more requirements on
uh the disclosure front what are you
seeing there what do you think is the
likely path that we'll get
there's no question there's gonna
there's gonna have to be more disclosure
there's gonna have to be more
transparency but the truth is and
this is something the entire industry
has to really get their head around
if we can get some policy even though it
will require additional compliance costs
more disclosure more transparency
it opens the floodgates of institutional
capital have been waiting to come into
the crypto market
just in a payment system alone
let's say four or five different stable
coins got licensed
it would be a phenomenal outcome because
you would for the first time be able to
get a one or two or three percent
indexed allocation from solving funds
running 500 to 900 billion dollars the
kind of guys that i service in the
indexing business i'm not the only
person doing it there's lots of others
but we talk to these funds all the time
and they say the same thing over and
over again
give me some policy show me i'm not
offside with the sec and i'll give you a
one percent allocation sometimes a three
percent allocation that goes for bitcoin
that goes for ethereum solana polygon
stable coins
just give me a regulated position that's
all they want so for all of the angst
and all the headaches and everybody
worrying and gnashing their teeth and
rubbing their hands together about
disclosure who cares let's get this
policy done and if you want if you want
to see bitcoin a hundred thousand
dollars that's how you're going to do it
you're going to get the sovereign wealth
funds to allocate to it i'm a believer
in that that's why i stay long in these
troubled and difficult times but i'm 100
compliant everything i touch is
regulated whether i own an exchange in a
country like canada or trying to buy a
license in the uae i'm working with the
regulator i don't want to be a crypto
cowboy
it just shows you what happens when
you're crypto cowboy you get wiped out
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time